from the start of the pandemic former
fda commissioner dr scott gottlieb was
in regular contact with key players in
the trump administration and his new
book uncontrolled spread why covet 19
crushed us and how we can defeat the
pandemic the next pandemic details the
mistakes that u.s officials have made
and may still be making in responding to
the virus dr gottlieb is also a member
of pfizer's board of directors and he's
here for his first live interview about
the new book how covet 19 crushed us and
why
i want to get to the book but because
you are on the board of pfizer and we
have this big pfizer news i want to get
to that first how soon could children
under the age of 12 start receiving
these vaccines so this data was on in
children 5 to 11 years old it's a 10
microgram vaccine so it's effectively
the same vaccine that's being used in
adults but in a lower dose pfizer tested
multiple doses to find the the optimal
dose that had the best compromise
between reducing the number of
vaccine-related side effects while still
providing efficacy that's on par with
what we saw in 16 to 25 year olds so
this is basically one-third of the
dose that's gonna that's already
approved in adults now that they have
the data that they could be ready to
file this within days with the food and
drug administration the fda has said
that the review of this vaccine they've
said publicly is going to be a matter of
weeks not months now having been at the
agency i interpret that to mean four to
six weeks so i think that there's a
possibility you could have a vaccine as
early as around halloween maybe a little
bit later you might lose a week here or
there but i think that if things go well
the fda looks at this data and feels
confident that it demonstrates that this
vaccine is safe and effective for
children five to eleven you could have a
vaccine within a month to six weeks one
of the compelling arguments in the book
here is that our response to pandemics
needs to be treated as a national
security issue with that in mind as we
look at an fda panel declining to
recommend booster shots for all
americans do you think they're moving
quickly enough well look i think what
they did was was appropriate they're
going to take a staged response to
trying to make boosters available to the
american population so what they said
was 65 and above and people who are at
risk of a severe outcome from covert
that could be expanded and maybe even
narrowed by the cdc once the cdc makes a
recommendation based on the fda's advice
but what i think you're going to see is
public health regulators now collect
more information to demonstrate that the
vaccines might be effective in people of
a younger age and they'll start walking
it down the age continuum so i think
that this is a start i think they
started with the population that's most
at risk of breakthrough infections which
is the older population they were
vaccinated a long interval ago and they
also have the worst outcomes if they do
contract coverage so i think it's a
prudent way to do this in a staged
fashion and i can see them now
collecting more data and then walking
this down to age continuum yeah i want
to get i want to follow up on that in
just a second but to go back to the
question about the kids was there
anything about side effects for children
who get the booster
so the profile in 5 to 11 looked on if
on par with what we saw in 16 to 25 year
olds pfizer tested three different doses
in children ages five to eleven to try
to find the optimal dose that provided
the same immune response in terms of the
kind of antibody production that you
were getting with the lowest possible
reactogenicity that's vaccine related
side effects like fever is an injection
site reaction the profile of the vaccine
in 5 to 11 actually looked better than
in 1625 in terms of the antibody
production and the side effect profile
but there was a real emphasis on trying
to find a dose that was optimized
insofar as it provided a sufficient
immune response but also the lowest
possible reactorgenicity and actually
the immune response between the 10
microgram dose and the 20 microgram dose
seemed comparable and the reason the 10
microgram dose was chosen was because it
seemed more tolerable in the young kids
you know the fda panel when you look at
israel israel has said listen everybody
needs to get the booster it's 10 times
more effective and the fda panel isn't
there yet israel seems to be way ahead
of us when it comes to fighting covert
why is that well look they're moving
more quickly they basically got 50
experts in a room to come to a decision
about making boosters available we have
a very iterative process here in the us
where multiple regulatory bodies weigh
in on it it's a slower process and we
also haven't been collecting data
systematically looking at boosters in
this country and also looking at
breakthrough infections the data we're
relying on is the israeli data so i
think that they were in a position to
move more quickly and roll it out more
quickly we'll get there they're the size
of an american state no they're a
country but they're like new jersey no
doubt your book examines what you call
the failures of the cdc what do you
think the cdc got wrong and what do you
think they're still getting wrong well
look i think at the outset they didn't
have the logistical capability to really
roll out a response that was of the
magnitude that was required they didn't
have the capability to handle a national
level public health crisis it's a very
retrospective mindset at the cdc they're
a high science organization that does
deep analytical work they don't have a
logistical capability so they couldn't
scale production of a test and
distribution of a test early on that got
us really behind they couldn't scale
production of a vaccine and actually
roll it out to the public they couldn't
collect information in a real-time
fashion and do analytical work to inform
real-time decision making so for example
for months they were still recommending
that people wipe down their groceries
and had a presumption that a lot of the
spread was through contaminated surfaces
when in fact it was and it was through
aerosols so it's deeply analytical they
would rather spend four months
collecting rigorous data doing
analytical work and come out with a
definitive answer rather than earth
surface real-time
information that can inform current
policy decision making you sound
frustrated by that scott
well it frustrated all of us look there
were a lot of things that felt very
conflicting that guidance on how far
should you stand apart from someone to
reduce your risk is it six feet is it
three feet is it ten feet it kept
changing the initial recommendation put
forward to the white house was actually
for ten feet of distance they eventually
revised it to six feet and subsequently
revised it to three feet we could have
done that a lot earlier that was the
single costliest advice that cdc gave
because it forced many schools to stay
closed because they couldn't provide for
six feet of distance between now listen
get it right you called it arbitrary
which is not a word you want an
association with health guidance uh dr
scott gottlieb who will not be invited
to the cdc holiday party this year but
has a lot of good information here in
the book it's called uncontrolled spread
and it goes on sale tomorrow dr gottlieb
thank you very much thanks a lot thank
you so much eye opening stuff in this
book indeed